uh but first I want to start a word
about what the media mob is calling a
monument to white supremacy remember
that now according to NBC News NBC news
with Tom broka no anyway the the border
wall was never about security instead it
was a reminder to uh uh Latinos that
they're not welcome in America in 2020
Biden ran with a simple promise uh not
one foot of border wall will be will
built Wilt built Trump campaigned on um
Build That Wall are you willing to tear
that wall down no I'm there will not be
another foot of Wall constructed on my
Administration okay really cuz today
after letting in over what 7 million
illegal immigrants it'll be 8 million in
three years as president and turning
every major US city into a border City
Border Town and causing chaos and
suffering Coast to Coast now the Biden
Administration decided that the border
wall uh might not be so racist after all
H in fact the White House they just
waved a whopping 26 environmental
federal laws to expedite the
construction of a new wall in Texas now
of course they didn't have to make these
waivers they could have fought this out
in court they could have battled it out
there for the next couple of years they
could have blocked any appropriated
funds but according to the DHS secretary
May orcus the guy that kept telling us
the borders closed the bord secure he is
now saying quote there is presently an
acute and immed an immediate need to
construct physical barriers and roads in
the vicinity of the border of the United
States in order to prevent unlawful
entries into the United States that's
from the Department of Homeland Security
secretary one of the guys that's been
lying to us now for three years uh now
get this information the administration
just leaked the plan to deport
Venezuelans in mass now mayorcas is now
saying there is no new Administration
policy the one that they gave us
yesterday that I just read to you didn't
happen despite the 26th wave laws the
new border wall construction the money's
being appropriated to it and now they
got exposed as having a plan to deport
people from Venezuela well now of course
May orcus is lying this is a cya after
his boss Joe Biden had a slightly
different message today apparently
nobody told Joe what his his
administration went was planning and his
hands are tied he said Trump and those
mean rascally republicans in Congress
they are the ones that are making him
build the wall they're the ones that
forced his hand and made him lift the
waivers on these environmental
construction issues take a look I'll
answer one question on the border wall
the border wall the money was
appropriate for the border wall I tried
to get them to reappropriate to redirect
that money they didn't they wouldn't and
in the meantime there's nothing under
the law other than they have to use the
money for what it was appropriated I
can't stop that do you believe the
border wall Works no he's lying again
the same people that said the border is
secure the same people that said that
there's no problem at the border now if
only there were 26 laws that Biden
didn't just wave to expedite the
construction well we might believe that
now today White House Press Secretary
Karen Jean Pierre was asked to provide
some clarification but as per usual she
was totally incapable of doing so take a
look the president said himself he asked
Congress to reappropriate this funds for
something that is more effective uh for
uh ways to do this in a smarter way as
it relates to border security measures
they refused this was announced back
back in June and now we're moving
forward and he said said in 2020 as a
candidate so after this law was passed
in 2019 that there will not be another
foot of Wall constructed in my
Administration how can you say that he's
not breaking that promise well what I
can say is that there's a law that the
DHS is is complying with we believe in
the rule of law and that's what we're
moving forward to with let's not forget
this was 6 months ago this was out there
6 months ago I know you guys are asking
me about this now but this was actually
not new and this was done 6 months ago
allow me to explain the predicament
democ R Now find themselves and you see
for these last few years they have put
their own Petty bitter politics above
what is the safety the security of you
the American people we see with our own
eyes what's happening we know they've
been lying to us and instead of just
working with Republicans on a sound
policy to secure the Border oh prevent
Fentanyl opioids and human trafficking
they wanted to smear slander bmer Donald
Trump and every Republican and character
iiz them as something that they are not
which is racist of course that was what
way more important take a look we can
secure our border without an ineffective
expensive wall and I demand that the
president
end his temper
tantrums and quest for a racist and
cobic
wall a wall is an immorality it's not
who we are as a nation on the subject of
trans National gangs let's be perfectly
clear the president's mideval vanity
project is not going to stop them so why
did they just adopt that policy now
after Biden was elected the White House
doubled down on stupid and assured you
the American people that not only are
border walls racist and xenophobic but
they don't even work that's what they
told you take a look the president
shares the concern about the lack of a a
workable immigration system um and that
impacts uh many of the border state um
leaders uh quite a bit of course uh
because there isn't an effective Asylum
processing system because we don't have
Smart Security we spent years investing
in a faulty border wall that was never
going to uh Be an Effective mechanism it
would waste taxpayer dollars on an
ineffective wall again an ineffective
wall that can't even withstand heavy
winds let alone sophisticated criminal
smuggling networks we have talked about
the border wall here in in general as as
a way uh that it's been used in in a to
to you know to to close the border and
we feel that it is a policy that doesn't
work then as the crisis got really bad
more blatant lies from the White House
let's remind you sounds to most folks
like a crisis well look it's way down
now we've now gotten control precisely
that the border is closed nor could I
have been clear and contined to be so
which is the border is closed the United
States will continue to enforce our laws
and secure our border the Border um we
are working to make the Border more
secure you're confident this border
secure we
have a secure Border in that that is a
priority for Any Nation including ours
and our Administration we agree that uh
the Border is secure bord is closed
border is secure they're all full of
Adam Schiff aren't they now just don't
believe Your Lying Eyes Don't Look at
video after video after video showing
Caravans of illegal immigrants pouring
across the border those eyes of yours
are lying to you forget about the
makeshift shelters under bridges and the
overcrowded cages where Biden detained
women and children in the middle of a
pandemic and forget about the taxpayer
funded late night uh flights that they
had to obscure airports full of illegal
immigrants in nearly every state in this
country look away as the illegals line
the streets of Chicago pack entire four
or five-star hotels in New York City
ignore the cartels charging admission
into the us while smuggling deadly drugs
uh into our country forget about the
100,000 Americans who die every single
year under Biden from those drugs if the
Biden Administration is willing to
blatantly lie repeat reply lie to your
face about a crisis this big this
obvious it really does make you wonder
are they ever ever going to tell us the
truth from inflation to Ukraine to
Biden's frequent trips to the beach to
the weaponization of the justice
department I'd still like to know who
brought that cocaine into the White
House they did a whopping 10day
investigation and had no conclusion I
have a suspect in mind I don't know
about the rest of you can we ever trust
the administration to be h honest about
anything truth be told the only reason
that may orcus is even lifting a finger
at the border is because of pole numbers
this has everything to do about
reelection they even know that those
videos that we're watching every night
look bad on them so they decide to of
course send out a new app that will
import people from all over the world
and you get to pick one of 43 cities
that you want to move to and Joe Biden
will let you in that way but it won't be
as cas chotic like the border the entire
Biden White House is more than happy to
ignore what is a real true crisis the
border is not closed The Border's not
secure and then they want to smear
Republicans smear Donald Trump virtue
signal everybody but the American people
I hope you are not all not buying these
lies hell even Democrats aren't buying
it the Democratic governors of Illinois
New York both now ripping Joe Biden over
his failure at the border that they now
have to suck it up pay for and now the
previous president who was smeared for
securing the border and protecting the
country is awaiting an apology anyway
better yet Biden should apologize to you
the American people whose lives have
been ruined because of Joe's dereliction
of juty uh Duty hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else